allô c'est une structure gonflable qui
se monte en quelques minutes bien
pratique car ces maîtres nageurs vont
arpenter le département tout l'été
aujourd'hui ils sont sur le plan d'eau
de bourgueil une douzaine de petits
baigneurs sont là pour apprendre les
bonnes techniques
aujourd'hui on va reprendre les
mouvements de brasse et on va aussi
travailler sur le dos le problème de la
respiration est effectivement et les
primordial et là on travaille même sur
les enfants qui savent nager on se rend
compte qu'on a un travail à faire sur la
respiration et sur la coordination des
mouvements des fois aussi
oui surtout embrasse embrase puisque on
peut avoir des nages dissymétrique alors
que la brasse et qu ils nagent
symétrique donc voilà on corrige les
pointes de pieds pour qu'ils aient des d
appui plus important dans l'euro que la
natation soit plus facile et le style
plus agréable quoi l'apprentissage est
basée avant tout sur le jeu
ainsi les enfants dépassent plus
rapidement leurs appréhensions ont
croisé les mains dans le montant eh bien
j'ai bien aimé mettre la tête sous l'eau
ça ne s'est pas peur ça non je sais qu
cioran tombiez des moyens pour nager en
fait à mon frère il voulait m'aider à
nager sauf qu'il n'y arrivait pas est-ce
que c'était pas les bons gestes que je
vais faire il faut mieux avoir un maître
nageur tu trouves c'est beaucoup mieux
cette opération est réalisée sur les
plans d'eau du département
car le constat a été fait qu'en milieu
rural du fait du manque de piscines plus
d'enfants en fin de primaire ne savent
pas bien nager doivent passer un petit
test qui va leur permettre en fait de
pouvoir se sortir de situations
difficiles dans l'eau afin qu'ils soient
déjà préparé pour la sixième et aussi
pour permettre aux enfants qui n'ont pas
la possibilité d'aller en piscine de
deux passés avec ses maîtres nageurs
itinérant voilà un bon moyen d'apprendre
à nager à ses enfants
histoire aussi pour les parents de
passer des vacances plus tranquille et
rassurer